you talked about feminism you mentioned
feminism and I I completely agree with
what you're saying in the sense that
feminism started for a reason because
women wanted the right to vote and they
weren't they didn't have educational
opportunities and they couldn't go work
there were there were things that men
could do in society that women were
being denied
but now the movement has been distorted
and it's a very pro-promiscuity movement
it's encouraging women to sleep around
that that's empowering and I'm curious
what your take is on that component like
there is a new wave of women now that
believe it's good for them
to sleep around with a bunch of guys to
not be monogamous to you know get an
only fans to follow that route
is that good for women a and is that
appealing to men the thing is
to each they own
um
there are some people that is going to
be good for them
I don't think it's going to be good for
everybody right more than is it good for
women or is it bad for women
my take is more be accountable for what
you do if you decide to do that
taking conservation of what's going to
come with that
you want to you want to have an only fan
you want to sleep around you want to you
want to be an ex-worker that's fine do
you do you
but you have to understand that certain
things and certain aspects of your life
are going to change
know that some people some men are not
going to be
geared towards that is going to be a
very very very very lonely life
I have exported friends they tell me all
the time it's all fun and games and we
all talk about the money and we all talk
about the this and that and
it's a very very lonely life
it's just like I work it's exactly like
a superstar I've worked in a five-star
hotel in Montreal and all the superstars
were going there and I was my job was to
basically serve their their their
um that put their meal whenever they
ordered and stuff like that it's a very
lonely life you want a superstar life
it's lonely because you do a show you go
out there you have a bunch of love
everybody screams your name everybody
says you're the great you go back to
your hotel room alone
the parallel with only fans is that you
put yourself out there you get a lot of
love you get all these guys paying pain
pain
but when you're trying to have be
intimate with someone it's not
everybody's going to be able to look at
you and be like yeah that's what I
really want you want to do that
I don't really I'm not I'm not gonna be
like it's bad for you whatever I ain't
your mom I ain't your dad yeah but you
have to be accountable accountable
accountability is much more important
than
that then whether it's good for you or
bad for you if you're taking your
accountability and you you take that
and you know your conscious of what's
gonna what might happen the reality of
that job the reality of the situation
you wanna a lot of women nowadays are
telling are telling people I want to
have a kid by myself
I want I don't care if I have
okay
but be accountable about what you're
going to put on that child like I'm not
talking about a woman that was with
someone and the dude left right or
something happened that's an unfortunate
that's that's not what we're talking
about talking about by Design like
talking about you decide you took the
corporate decision to do that right like
that's hard it's hard to raise a kid
if
so and I think I think that's that's
what I'm getting at in terms of what my
message to women is always and I speak
to women in particular I am a female so
I'm directing that message but my
message is do what you want live the
life you want make the choices you want
but you have to understand that these
choices have consequences and what I'm
seeing is a disconnect between that
there are women that are saying well I
want to be promiscuous and I want to you
know have an only fans and I want to do
this but I also want to be respected as
if I don't I want to be treated as if I
don't I want guys to forget about that
and want to wife me up and the guys
don't don't like it they don't like a
high body count on women and they don't
like this stuff so I'm trying to shake
reality into women I don't even think
that
having a high body count for men and
women
damaging
that's true but the reality is that
women
don't care as much about guy's body
count and their past as guys care about
a woman's past and her body count so
that's just now that we can say that's
not fair that's not just why is it that
way you know it should because I'm not a
fan of promiscuity across the board I
just think it's bad in general my
personal opinion I don't tell anybody
what to do but I just don't think it's
good for society
but the reality is that the women don't
care the same way about the guy's body
count so you have to just deal in
reality and the bottom line is a guy if
he goes to his early 20s and has a bunch
of meaningless or whatever you know he
gets his body count up to say 20
whatever
a woman's not going to look at that and
say well he has body count 20. I'm not
going to want to be with him but a guy
will look at a woman and be like she was
hopping in and out of everybody's bed I
don't want that I want to go with this
girl over here who has a body count of
two and is teaching preschool and like
not a headache for me you know
so I just I'm trying to get people I
guess just to look at reality and like
make your decisions but like
it's gonna affect your life just be just
be conscious of
the reality that we live in
and what who you're dealing with like
wanting everybody to change because you
wanna according to how you move it's not
possible
whether it's good for good intentions or
bad intentions whatever if you want
everybody to to move I'm sorry everybody
if you want everybody to move the way
you move
and understand the way yeah it doesn't
work like that it doesn't so
yeah they have to be conscious more than
to me more than promiscuity more than
more than all of that be accountable
there's a phrase that's been going
around for a couple of years it says uh
the future is female
okay
I think the future is accountability
so we made we made a church a shirt like
that the future is female and it's by
it's been accountability because I think
that's more important just know just
know how just know
how it's supposed to be out there be
conscious right it's like you're just
walking in the your privilege of not no
I want oh yeah but pipe down so I
understand I understand that whether
you're a fan of promiscuity or not
understand that it might be it might get
difficult so if you go to war
you want to be a soldier there's going
to be consequences if I do certain jobs
there's going to be consequences
if I want to be a CEO of a company or
whatever and I have to put a lot of
hours well my family are probably going
to suffer
doing the job that I do I'm here and
there
I have to make time for certain I have
choices to make according to the reality
of the thing you have to be accountable
Logan though that
that future is female like it just I
mean I am a female you don't like that
well I don't like it because
well two reasons first of all future
should be for me the future is good
people like good quality citizens like
men women I don't care like I don't like
that that immediately makes it like
oh women are going to do all the good
things and women are going to do and
what happens to all the guys I have a
little boy you know I have a
three-year-old son
I'm raising him to be a kind respectful
you know wonderful one day man
and are we now in a culture that's going
to disregard him as oh you can't really
accomplish good things because women are
here now
why why you have to earn that spot so
let each individual man or woman earn
that spot based on their character not
based on their gender because because
I'm able to sit down and when I haven't
talked with people like that
I understand what the message is beyond
the future is female what is that to you
they want to prop up female they want to
give uh this
um
like self-confidence they want to you
know they want to prop up the EGO of
women that was not just as bad for all
these years I understand that
can I swear sure okay go for it all
right
go for it nothing's off the table on
this okay it's just it and and I know
they want to prop up and they want they
want to do this they want to make people
feel better the thing is
the marketing is [ __ ] up
it's not good marketing
because that's not what the message of
other people do it's not good marketing
it's not good
because imagine if it was written live
and it was pre-taped the marketing is
messed up it's not good marketing
just like if you're talking about uh
toxic masculinity I understand what they
trying to say when they say that
the marketing is [ __ ] up it's not
gonna Mark it's not what it is
I'll come whenever we talk about racism
and we say let's say we have a white
person that's being racist towards a
black person we call that racism when a
black person is uh racist towards
another black person we call that
classism uh we call that self-hate
whenever we have a lighter shade of
black like we have all these names for
all these different types of racism
depending of who does it
but what if we talk about uh
feminism
when a guy is being rude to a woman it's
toxic masculinity when a girl is being
rude to a man toxic masculinity when
everything is no let's let's let's see
we know where it's from
but let's let's just know what this is
yeah but it's from it's from it's
because it's oppression yeah okay I get
it yeah whatever but that's by Design
you know like you're saying you're
saying it's bad marketing right and I
think to to someone a thinking person
who's not agenda driven like yourself it
just looks like that's just bad like why
are you doing it like that but I
actually think it's perfect marketing
for what they're trying to do because if
you look at television and you look at
film movies men are consistently being
painted as weak as dumb as you know the
Lesser sex I'm watching the handmaid's
tale right now and they've got scenes in
there that I'm like the guy looks like
he needs like he he's playing the female
role essentially and the woman they have
prepped up as the person who can you
know don't worry I've got it all under
control in many of these scenes and
that's something that happens all the
time in film and TV so I think they say
toxic masculinity
because it's a gender driven and you
know you're saying well women were
oppressed you know prior so you're
trying to see the lens of like making up
for bad decisions in the past but
I feel like history plays out that way
sometimes and it's like yeah we weren't
always perfect we were making big
mistakes you look at slavery I mean
there were things that happened in this
country in particular and others that
were just bad right but you can't in an
effort to like correct some of that you
can't over correct it and now
you know vilify
Men at Large because women didn't have
the right to vote now modern men get
vilified that's crazy to me if you want
to watch the full episode you're going
to click right here and if you want to
ask me a question one on one you want to
do a one-on-one face time with a group
of your friends whatever you want you
need to download manect right now click
right here and let's get talking
[Music]